the sound of sporadic gun battles echo
across the ukrainian capital kiev
russian invasion forces are closing in
on the city the president vladimir
zelensky made a bleak but defiant video
address
good evening everyone our troops are
here our citizens are here all of us are
here protecting the independence of our
country and it will continue to be this
way glory to our defenders glory to
ukraine glory to heroes
but satellite images show massive
russian reinforcements waiting in
reserve at various staging posts just
across the borders from ukraine russia
has the numbers stacked in its favor and
vladimir putin shows no sign of
relenting you're sure
once again i appeal to the servicemen of
the ukrainian armed forces don't let
neo-nazis and bandaids use your children
your wives and old people as human
shields
take power into your own hands it seems
that it will be easier for us to come to
terms with you than this gang of drug
addicts and neo-nazis who settled in
kiev and took all ukrainian people
hostage
ukraine's army is putting up a fight
this russian artillery convoy near the
southern city of herson was wiped out as
it traveled along the highway from
crimea
and the defiance of the soldiers in a
ukrainian position on snake island in
the black sea
has captured the public imagination
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
minutes later the entire garrison of 13
was wiped out by a russian bombardment
russia says ukrainian civilians need not
be worried but this civilian motorist
would disagree his car run over by a
russian personnel carrier which appeared
to deliberately target his vehicle
remarkably the man was pulled out alive
from the wreckage
in contrast to the situation elsewhere
in dinipro a city with a population of a
million people it's relatively quiet but
even here there's no escaping the sense
of foreboding and tension
i don't want to go away from my land or
my country i will stay here i will fight
here for my freedom for my independence
from my nation for us and for me
especially this is this this innovation
absolutely
unbelievable we're in the center of the
capital of ukraine in a war that's
costing so much
in lives money and faith
yet
there's an eerie silence here
no one to be seen around this area
the streets over there pretty deserted
those that are around are invariably in
bomb shelters i have to cope but
really we are struggling by getting
stuck in here
that's the thing that we can can't
escape at the moment
her son voiced some optimism it's very
terrifying
but um we're coping and
i'm sure that in about
a few days
it should be fine now it should settle a
little bit
for those who want to escape
time is running out
and at kiev's main railway station the
platforms have been crammed with people
trying to get onto trains and flee the
city
[Music]
this exodus is regularly interrupted by
air raid sirens which send anyone out in
the open
scurrying for the safety of the nearest
metro station more than a hundred
thousand ukrainian civilians have
already fled to neighboring countries a
steady flow of people crossing into
romania hungary and poland
in the country they've left behind cases
full of weapons are being handed to
anyone who wants them all men aged
between 18 and 60 are banned from
leaving the country now
their president is telling his soldiers
you are all we have
this is turning into a bloody war this
country believes the fight is for
ukraine's very existence as an
independent state
andrew simmons al jazeera kiev